I'm Jason Momoa, and Smarles is popping my cherry. Smart less. Jason, you look, why do you look so clean cut today? Yeah, you look really good. Because I washed. I'm fresh from the shower. I'm glad we were a little delayed today because I was running a little behind. And it occurred to me as I was racing through my rituals there of pre, during, and post shower.
Sure. That my loop has gotten quicker. I'm, you know, the sort of, how long does it take you guys from start to finish? Like, oh, shit, I got to get out the door. I got to get out the door. I got to get dressed, got to get out the door. Are you like a 10 minute, 5 minute, 15 or a half hour? I'm a 5.
Yeah, it takes me a long, long time. Does it? Yeah. Yeah, because what we're enjoying right now doesn't just happen. What's you're enjoying right now? Yeah, it takes some work. No, because my hair, it gets super, super, super poofy and big, and it takes forever to just do it so I can walk out the door.
And then so how do you get it down? How do you depoof? Is there a product? Ideally, I have to let it air dry it. Because if I blow dry it, it's like a massive. Yeah, and then it's really humid over the UK. Yeah, it's super humid and I put water in it with the product and then I spray it. It takes a long time.
Oh, my God. We should post on the website just your ritual just for people who are looking to, you know. And Willie, you just, you're just a five minute. I'm a five and go. Truly, just five minutes. I think so. Get your clothes off, get wet, get dry, get dressed. Yeah, I'm a quick shower person.
I'm a really quick shower person Always have been I'll obviously have those moments We have a longer shower But I'm a really quick I'm gonna kind of in and out Well let's stop there for a second What are those moments
Where you're taking a longer shower Is that when you're putting hands on yourself? No. No No I'm not My shower is not my jackshack It's not?
No that's a separate I told you that's a separate building out back Are we seeing you Are we seeing you in your jackshack right? you might be you might be it's a whisper booth slash jackshack no it's uh shower time is long showers is usually like winter time and you're kind of chilled to the bone um well what about you jay how fast can you do it i'm a i'm a 15 minute all in i can be in the car um oh really well yeah yeah that's from getting undressed showered redressed down the stairs
out of the door maybe i'm 15 as well i bet you're 15 i might be because i do a lot of other stuff you know, grab me everything, do a little quick moisturize. Yeah, that's another thing. I've done as my products, my products have increased as I've gotten older. I've got creams and ointments and fucking... Oh, so you do have cream. All kinds of shit. This is you creamed.
Oh, I'm fully hydrated right now. Okay. Yeah, yeah. Check me out. Okay. I mean, if you could smell me too. You do have like a... You've got a little bit of a cute boy haircut right now.
Yeah. Hey, thanks, man. Yeah. Yeah, it looks good. Yeah, it does. It's kind of a little... Don't start. acting boyish.
Well, no, no, but after the podcast, if you've got some extra time, maybe. Jesus. Hey, Will, who's your fucking guest today? You seem pretty chipper about this guest. I am. I am. I like our guest. I like our guest a lot. Your guest is not intimidating.
He's already making a lot of noise. Yeah. Jason, you better mind your P's and Q's. Really? Yeah. Why? Because he'll reach through the screen and he'll grab you. Is this a hockey player that could tune me up?
He's not, but he probably, if he grew up in Canada, you would have been. But he didn't, he grew up in Hawaii. Oh, is that right? Yeah. And, you know, he's done a lot of stuff that we love. Barack Obama. He's done a lot of, he's done a lot of, it's not a terrible guest. Did I get it?
Yes, no, you didn't get it. But he's done a ton of movies. This guy's been in, like, so many freaking huge movies. I'm going to say, like, I'm going to try to do it so you can just bury it a little bit. You know, things, like I'm not going to say, the obvious ones, A Lego Part 2 movie He was in. Minecraft movie
You know him from Fall Guy You know him from Fast X From the Fast X From the Fast series But you also know him From the Aquaman movies And Zach Snyder's Justice League And he has a new show
This is Jason Maimon Let's just bring him out Apple TV TV Awards Jason Mamma Woo Jason Mamma Got it You can't swing these guys
Value me I can guess it What's up? What's up? Look at this guy Jason What is your What's your, babe, we got to go.
Come on, get dressed. What's your, I got to get undressed shower and redress. What's your out the door? Do you do what Jason does? You cream on your face? Yeah, he creams on his face. What's me in and out of the door? How quick you got to go?
How quick if you're dirty and you need to shower and get dressed to go out. Yeah, 10, 15 minutes, easy. That's it. What about when the hair was super long? Arm pits, nuts, ass, and then fucking out of the dough. But the hair, what about when the hair? What about when the hair was super long? That's a beast.
My hair is super long. It's just... Up and a pony? Yeah, it's just in the back, yeah. I'm not cutting my hair again. No. Never again. Never?
I don't want to. Does it take like two hours to drive? Is it about that? To drive my hair? Yeah, it must, right? No. You just take it outside. Yeah.
When you get out and you just let it air dry, you probably look like an 80s rock, like heavy metal guy, right? Just pool everywhere. I mean, real men's drive. Let's be true. You have to, like, don't you have to, like, don't you, you got to condition that shit and you got to watch out for your split ends and all that. You have to put stuff in your hair, I don't put shit in it, man. You don't.
You walk around with a bunch of hair ties on your wrist. I do, I do. You do, right? I do. Yeah, there is. I do, I do, too, the hair ties, but I just. J.B, you spend a lot of time worried about your split ends? Is this something that keeps you like?
You know, when my hair was long for a second there, I was like, oh, shit, this is a, this is a nightmare. It's not fun. Oh, it's easy. My mom, my mom, do you. really do do you do all the stuff that jason does too with the creams and the things and the and the he's younger than us he doesn't need to yet no no of course i put a cream on my face but my face yeah it feels dry yeah because i mean i feel like there's a lot of chlorine in the water just when you know i'm in london right now and it's like everything so am i you just like yeah you're just like
sure sure sure um yeah i definitely i definitely what part what part of time i'm just other careful jason i'm at the rosewood right now i was supposed to be in new york but then the flight got canceled oh will here comes will you know i live in the rosewood too get him get him well everyone's getting along come on first question arnette let's go listen hey f you man you just you just completely uh uh you know hijacked him wait is that cold brew up there or is that or is that a logger this is Guinness that's Guinness yeah because it's what it's like 6 p.m. over there go get it yeah it's uh yeah yeah it's six p.
Are you getting after it tonight? What's going on tonight? No, I'm going to spend the time with my lady. She's in here doing a movie. So my intention was to be, I was supposed to do Fallon tonight. So I was in, I'm in Budapest right now. Yeah, I'm in Budapest shooting Dune. So I flew in, and then we got stuck in a storm,
and then I couldn't get in. And so I was supposed to do Fallon. And, but I mean, I can do you guys from there. Now we got stuck doing us. Yeah. No, I fucking, you guys, you guys are popping my chair, you guys. You're the first podcast I've ever done. No way!
You're the first podcast I've ever done. I've never agreed to do these because I'm going to get myself in trouble. So please don't get me in trouble. Listen, I, listen, you know this, Jason. The first time that we met was like at some adventure or something. But you're one of those dudes. The first time we met, I felt like I knew you. We freaked the fuck out is what we did.
Yeah, we freaked out. Yeah, you were outside smoking. I was like, yeah. Yes. You grab me and wrap me. I was like, oh, shit. I love this. Same thing with Bateman, though.
Well, this is the same thing. This is one of the great guys. It was the same thing, man. Yeah. You are a good dude. So, wait, so you had to cancel on Fallon because of whether, I wonder who Fallon calls. Everyone's got like that call. Like, I think, I forget who Kimmel said his call is when a guest drops out last minute.
You've got somebody you can get on the blower to get, hey, can you drive down and do the show tonight? Because, you know, they're live. I wonder who calls. Yeah, well, I mean, it was a pre-tape. So, I mean, it's, I've been, I've had to, I've done it a few times. Yeah, you've been. You've been a call-a-friend? I've last-minute it for Kimmel before, and I've last-
You are one of the great all-time talk-show guests. That is true. They'd call them, they'd be like, so-and-so, like their flight got canceled, or they were sick or whatever, and you come and make a jackass out of yourself for 15 minutes. No, you are one of the great all-time talk-show guests. Jay, Mama, how are you, how, do you like the talk shows? I do, I love, yeah.
I mean, listen, I think this is probably way better to do because it's way more personal and you get time. Well, this is just a conversation. bullshit thing but like you don't have to get out you don't have to dress up and like you just show up yeah you gotta have bits on those talk shows yeah it just depends on what you're supporting like right now I'm doing like my dream project like it's my
brave heart or my dance is wolf so what do I've worked my no no no chief of war so the chief of show that I'm coming out is 1790s Hawaii so I created it oh no way I wrote it no way I directed it and actually it's 90s he did all of this August 1st on Apple TV yeah so directed all the episodes no no
No, no, no, no, I didn't. I mean, I couldn't. I mean, it couldn't do it all of it. But I mean, I created the show. I co-created it and wrote it with my partner. But it's been like my 10-year project that I did with Apple, and it's all like just right after the white man came. So it's like, it's 1790s Hawaii. Wow. It's all in Alela Hawaii. So it's all in the language, which is, you know, very, it's a, it's a pretty big deal. Whole thing subtitled?
It's a subtitled. But it does, it slowly gets into English. but oh buddy it's my character actually like he he leaves Hawaii and he goes out to the world and he comes back with all the weapons but he basically gets to see the world and just see what's coming and then he unites it's
it's about the unification of the Hawaiian Islands Sean that's your approach when you're in the UK right just slowly get into English so Jason talk a little bit how did it start what was the genesis of this whole idea of doing this project I mean it's just it's never
happened before you know these images um my great great great grandfather has never even seen anything like this so we've only had these in paintings or in museums so nothing has ever existed like this yeah i know nothing about yeah so it's just like wanting to make something about king come mehamehah and just like our people and all the different things that were happening but i needed something that would encompass a lot of things that were going on it's like telling abraham lincoln's story and you're like that's why spielberg did gettysburg you know it's just it's just the little moments of his life but it's like how do I encompass
this whole area of Hawaii and this character like helped me do that how was what was what was it was this the settlement the settling of Hawaii like when the white man came over was it was it a
was it like a war was it contentious was it smooth was it I mean I think when I think when Cook first came they were you know kind of blown away and what happened is I think, you know, he left. They kind of snuck onto the ship and maybe took a couple things. And then they executed one of them, I think.
And that pissed everybody off. And so they left. And when they got stuck in a storm, they came back. And that's when all hell broke loose. And so that's when Cook died on the big island. Wait a guy. But, yeah. So when Captain Cook died in Hawaii.
Oh. So, but this is after Cook. So, but it's, it's, it's, it's, it's just a really beautiful story. It's very much like an Arthurian kind of, you know, the Guinevere, Sir Lancelot, King Arthur story between, you have this love story at the same time, you have us, a character that leaves Hawaii, he goes to China, he goes to the Philippines, he goes to Alaska, and he comes back, and that's what he brings back all the weapons. And he sees the outside world, and he sees what's coming. Yeah. And you're going to see what's happening in Hawaii at the time. So it's a very huge, huge.
show yeah wow yeah dude it's so cool that's really great as a guy who's coming out on my birthday guys is that right august oh wait happy birthday uh yeah wait so so going to do that and come being being you know uh being Hawaiian and and coming home and doing this story that obviously means a lot to you was it uh i imagine there must have been a bunch of moments you had where it was like almost spiritual or you just like felt like the the fact that you got to do this and tell this story must have been pretty rad. I mean, I don't think there's anything bigger that I'll do because, I mean, it's not like I'm playing a superhero
or something like that. I'm playing my ancestors. I'm actually like, you know, was there pressure in that? Did you feel like kind of, yeah. I mean, like I'm putting on outfits that you're not even allowed to. I mean, they're just in museums. So the things that we're wearing, I wouldn't even be allowed to wear.
You know what I mean? Like, so it's, even extras were wearing it. So it was a huge thing. And at the same time, it's like, You know, the movies we had were from, like, El Toro, they're from New Zealand. Like, once we're warriors or, like, whale rider. Like, there's all these Polynesian stories. But there hasn't been something from Hawaii.
So it really kind of united Polynesia because there's not really, everyone comes to Hawaii. They make movies there, but they don't make Hawaiian movies. They don't make movies about us. And so, you know, we're a part of America. We just, no one really knows our story. And so I feel like this, this thing is something that's never happened before. And at the same time, we didn't really have the resources. And so it's really united Polynesia because we got Tongin, Samoan, Fijian, Tahitian, Taishin, Māori,
all these different cultures helping us tell this story. So it's been really wonderful. How old were you when you, how long did you grow up before you left? My parents got divorced when I was six months old. So it was pretty shitty. I left at a very young age, but I was raised in Iowa, which is really, when most people think it's great, I think it's really great. I grew up in the Midwest, which is, if you grow up in the Midwest, you kind of know that it's a pretty spectacular place.
You grow up with, like, I agree. I mean, my work ethic, family values, like, it's a very strong place. Having said that I grew up where Bridges of Madison County was made. So I grew up literally, like, not a race. So I'd go from literally a small country town to going to, like, kind of the reservation of the Hawaiian side. It's a whole, basically where I'm from is all local side. And it's not really being accepted there or being accepted there. So it was a bit of a, it's a bit of like trying to figure that out.
But I would spend my summers with my father. And, you know, and then I would, you know, go to school with my mother. So you were born in Hawaii, then went to Iowa, then went back to Hawaii? Yeah. So when I was in college, I went out to Colorado and that's where I was going. And then I kind of, my family, I come from one of the biggest serve families. in Hawaii. My great uncles
like Buffalo Kualana. I come from a long list of amazing watermen. So I kind of went over there to like really sink in with my family, get to know my father better. And I was 19. And then a TV show came and I ended up,
I was just folding t-shirts at the family surf shop and then I ended up getting a lead role in this really horrible show that just fucking killed me. But I found acting. You know what I'm talking about, baby. Yeah, yeah.
Right. So you're working in a surf shop. All the fucking holes we've got to dig ourselves. That's right. Were you, what were you doing? So in Hawaii, so you're working at the family surf shop. Were you surfing? How did you, did you get on a board?
Yeah, yeah. I was torn in big waves. Like this movie came out called In God's Hands. And my cousin, Brian Kilana, he was the one who was towing in with Laird and all and stuff. And so I was like, what am I doing? I can go surf these big ways of my family. So I took the summer off and I went over there.
And then the moment I was supposed to go back to school, I got the lead role, so I was just like, it was... Wait, wait, on the surfing part, did you... Have you been towed into waves? Like, do you surf those? Come on. Yeah, yeah. I towed in like a 20-foot wave with, uh, out in McCool. Unleaders.
This is a real man, you guys. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I mean, I actually drowned in Laird's... You got once towed to the service stage, to the BMW stage, didn't you?
They towed you. Yeah, well, actually, it's only on a flatbed. My car, because of the front faring, you couldn't tow it, so you got to put it. on a flatbed but um i did ride up front with the guy yeah no way up front with the guy wait mama tell me wait you almost drowned for real yeah i uh i was doing this paddle we we we we went in at jaws oh my god josh is the real deal and we and we we did like a 14th it's made it's like a 13 mile paddle with uh from i was with dave kalama my friend joe flanagan and uh and uh larat hamilton we paddle like 13 miles down the coast
and you're kind of almost a mile offshore and then my leash snapped and I was about we're about seven miles into it and my leash snapped and the it's so windy on Maui and so the board just went I couldn't even see it anymore Sean you were going to say your leash snapped
once too but it was cool because you didn't have to pay the guy right because it's like you snap it that hard on me it's going to break I told you I know and you know what I did that on it ended up being free don't yank on it so hard it'll fucking break.
And then we ended up getting married 20 years later. Hey, listen, Jason. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Wait, so tell me, when you're in that position of almost drowning, what is your brain like? Yeah, it's so scary. So you know what's happening. Do you have a protocol of what to do in that moment?
Are you even thinking clearly enough to know how to save yourself? Yeah, yeah. I mean, I was trained pretty well. Also, it was fine, so I was just, I took quite a few on the head. They're pretty big, like 10 foot, 10 foot Hawaiian waves, but I'm literally probably a half mile at that point offshore, and it was just, I was, it's actually this place is called shit fucks, and it's literally because there's all this water that pulls out and there's a dollar drinks on Thursdays.
And it just, it just, it pulls you out and you just get hit with these waves. So I was stuck in this crazy spot, which is probably the hour. Reef and unknown to me, I was really on the Outer Reef and they couldn't see me and I had my paddle and I was waving it and they couldn't see me and the ways were so big it was basically took my shorts off it was so fucking big. Hang on. I reached down, put the shorts back on. Shorts off at shit fucks.
I'm pretty sure that's in the village. Shorts were off at shit fucks. I looked in. I looked in and I was just like my daughter at that time was three months old and, uh, I was, I just, I lost it. I was like, oh, God. I couldn't. And who ended up saving you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, what ended up happened, I was out there for a while. And then I, I just couldn't see anyone coming to get me. And I couldn't move anymore. And my arms and my legs gave up after, you know, I was out there for a while. But Laird had to go in and then go all the way around me and paddle up behind me. So, like, it's a coastal paddle. So it goes with the trade winds.
So you're going down the coast. And then he came from behind, and I had already given up. My body stopped. Like, I couldn't move my arms anymore. And I bubbled down. And then my toe hit the outer reef. Like, I literally gave up. And I'm screaming inside.
And my foot just hits the outer reef. And I don't know if it was a fucking whale or, like, just could be one rock. But I just reached down, grab it. I jump up. I get hit by another wave. and I dig my feet into the coral and I'm literally in the middle of the ocean and I'm just, I could barely
put my lips above. It's just to breathe and get a break but I had already given up so it's like you've already given up and died and have the second chance at it and then I still stayed out there for like 10 minutes and I was hanging on the side of this reef and then I hear Laird come from behind
and he's on my board, towing his board and I get on and he's like, you're right and I'm like, no. I get back on the board and we start paddling he's like you got to go out out and so we just keep paddling out and I just keep trying to go over every wave
I lose the board he loses the board it's just the shit fucking it is brutal getting out of the spot and so we end up getting out really far on the end like pretty much on the shelf of Maui
and I have seven more miles to paddle my feet are covering blood and I'm just literally like my ancestors just paddling the rest of this way head down and we get out And I mean, I could have been trolling.
There could be sharks everywhere, but I'm just, like, trolling this whole fucking coast. Bloods all over the board. All this blood you're dropping, too. And we get in, and that's, I used to smoke. And I used to smoke, like, two, three packs a day. I'd roll the pouch. I couldn't stop for my kids.
Couldn't stop for my ex. I couldn't stop smoking. And the moment I came out, I never smoked again. Like, I just died. I just died. Like, I tried and tried, but I couldn't do it again because I just, I gave up. Like, I gave up my life.
Do you remember the moment you felt that you were saved, that you, that he actually, that you actually got through it? Do you remember that moment? I remember seeing him, but I was like, but, you know, I was 10 minutes dead already, you know? That would have been 10 minutes. Had there not been the outer reef, like, had there not been some, you know, and I do believe my answers. I do believe my, you know, I prayed to my grandmother and my grandfather. I mean, I was, I was reaching. And I was in a bad position.
And you're stuck out there in that kind of way. It's no bored. You're fucked. And there's no way to swim in. It's just not. I don't have that. So it was a bad spot to be in. But I imagine that gives you like a, it's a pretty sharp contrast and gives you some perspective to, like you said, you quit smoking.
And that going forward from that moment, you're like, all right, I've been through some shit and everything else is kind of gravy. Did you have a little bit of that? You know, I did a little harder run. I think, you know, I have qualities that are, I don't know. I was pretty hard on myself that night. I didn't love a stupid shit. And I just really was, like, pissed on myself for the position I was in and probably tortured myself even more for the stupid shit that I did.
So I don't know. It was a bit of a hard learning curve, but I feel like I've always had that. My learning curves are pretty hard on me, so. You know, I was thinking about that the other day about how, you know, I find myself in a completely different life. than I was having in my in my 20s I mean as as everyone does you sort of you go through these stages and how how are you how are you finding your life now as a fully functioning
um you know professional that's able to write and direct and produce and star and and like you know take all these sort of adult meetings and like all this kind of shit that it doesn't sound like you were doing at all in in in your in your earlier sexual life like like like me too just being a you know a dickhead i think if you have yeah i think there's a potential that you you you have that needs to come out and i just until i met the people that actually like until i met my partners yeah i met the people that actually made me get those things out i was just bashing myself with addiction and drugs and i'm like yeah but a necessary stage that you're just burning yeah you go through that stage you've got to get it out yeah yeah
Because now's not a good time to do it. So it sounds like we were doing that stuff at a time when you're supposed to. But you do that really well such that you can now do this really well. And are you enjoying that? And do you have that kind of clarity and perspective? Like that was a version of Jason Mamoa. And now this is a version of Jason. And they're both me.
And I'm just going through it. 100%. Yeah. I mean, they're great. They're great. All the things that we did when we were younger. I'm glad I you know it wasn't handed out it was a very hard road to get where I'm at so yeah having said I've been you know I've been directing for last almost 12 years now I like that process I love producing I love not being just an actor I love being able to if someone's going to judge me on something like I took this choice I made all these choices sure instead of just being an actor it's nice just to go to the trailer and be an actor but I also love I mean this is the way my brain works I want to have a hundred things going on yeah and I'm going to be an actor I And I just love working.
I love, I just love being responsible for those things. Well, you also appreciate it because of all the things, Jason, like you were just saying. And I think I'm finding, I'm going through it right now at this age. I'm 55. Sorry, I was waiting for you guys to go, no way. Oh, yeah. Sorry. It's a delayed.
There's a delay. And, you know, I've just recently, truly, the last, I don't know, almost a couple weeks, I finally had this moment where I was like, I feel this kind of shift happening and this sort of cloud lifting and this thing happening in my life where I feel like I'm okay, I'm cool with who I am today.
And it took me going through a lot of different shit and it's different from any other period of my life. It's really, it's really rad and really profound. It's one of the gifts of getting older, right? Right, yeah. You start to care a little less about what other people perceive you as, and the artifice and the efforts you make to sort of convince those that you might be X, Y, or Z.
And it's like, no, I'm just A, B, or C. You know, like, this is just me. And if you see it, great. If you don't, that's okay, too. It's more, most important is that number one understands who number one is and that I'm okay with that. There's only one of me. And I hope you guys dig it. If you don't, there's other people to talk to.
A little bit. Yeah, totally. I think there's truth in that. um wait so momo you're talking about you did this shitty show but like uh uh you're first i guess that was your first acting gig right the thing you're talking about that you did in white you know what you was kind of cool about i mean like listen i fell in love with acting because i was a i was a biology major i was a science major and that's
what i wanted to do and so i um you know baywatch hawaii came and whatever i was 19 years old you got to make a hundred dollars being a extra and i was folding t-shirts for 60 and you got to meet a bunch of hot chicks and I was 19 years old and like yeah okay I'm gonna go on perfect yeah I was like 1300 people showed up down there and we went in and I ended up you know ended up getting the lead role I was supposed to go back to college and my mom's like what are you doing I'm like I don't want to watch why and she's like what I mean like you just you know I didn't know what's cool thing about it and but I fell in love with acting I basically watched tons of movies and every movie I'd watch I just play that character in the next day you know if I
watched fifth element I was Gary Oldman that day I thought if I watched fight clubs I was fucking Tyler Darden in that episode. And so, I mean, I literally just, it was practice and doing all that. And I just didn't give a shit. And I, I, but I fell in love with it. And having said that, every grip and like from catering to the grip, makeup, everyone, they're on my show, you know, I'm 47, 47, 46 on August 1st. And they're all did Chief of War with me. Wow.
And I'm coming home telling our people's movie. and, you know, I've dug myself out of massive, massive holes. Like, you know, I learned my, I went through college doing, you know, Stargate Atlantis and hiding in Canada and making a sci-fi show. But I learned how to do everything. I was like, listen, I'm going to shoot this myself. So I started at that point when I could write, direct, do all the stuff on my own because I was like 22 episodes, nine months of my life. Yeah. You know, it's just like banging out stuff.
And you're like, no, that was my college. And then I had an accident and took some time off. but I, you know, got married, had some kids, and then Game of Thrones came out, and then no one knew what the fuck to do with that guy. Right, right, right, right. You're kind of stuck in that jail of, like, until you get to the fourth season of it.
And I was like, while we did Game of Thrones, I did, I wrote, you know, co-wrote my first movie, and I did road to Paloma. And I was just like, fuck this. I made Pride of Gypsies, which is a bunch of actors, a group of friends, and we just made movies together.
And, you know, some of us were, we'd all hold the boom. We'd all do this. We'd all shoot. And so we all came, from that thing where it's just we did the work we edited it we shot it and that's how we kind of built you know i'm not going to wait for anything so we just kind of went about it that way because i was like no one's going to give me this shit you got to go you got to go get it so we wrote all our own
stuff yeah yeah that's cool you know i remember seeing you in game of thrones and i was like you just you're the character and the size of you i was just like my god this guy's such an an incredibly, you know, fit human being and the size of it, I was like, and then on, because your entrance, you're like, oh, my God, who's this guy? And then you start acting, you're like, oh, wow, he's like a brilliant actor.
And you have presence. He has such, you have such presence, apart from your physical, you just have presence as a person that's really magnetic. And I wonder, right, Sean? Like, like, yeah, I was just so surprised that, like, that, I know what you mean by,
well, what do we do with this guy? I was like, well, he's a great actor. That's what you do with him. You just plug him into any role. Was Game of Thrones, was that the first, was that a turning point? It must have been a turning point. That was the turning point.
You got to respect. But it was, it didn't, like, because he didn't say much, and even though I played, like, a really good character played it and did my job well, but it was, I mean, it's a thing where it's like, I'm a huge SNL fan.
Like, I love comedy. I just wanted to do comedy. That was the thing I grew up with SNL. It's all I wanted to do. Yeah, yeah, same. And you hosted twice? No one fucking knows me that way, so I didn't know. They just, you know, and they just use me as action or I don't say much.
And so it's a very weird thing to kind of live in that action and you're this and that. Because my mom and my dad are both painters, right? My mom, you know, I was raised watching rear window and like gone with the wind and Streetcar Name Desire. I was raised as a single mother that worked four jobs in Iowa. So it's like I didn't grow up, even like grew up into this body. I'm like, I'm a total, like an art nerd. I grew up in a different way. You just kind of like, this isn't really me.
This is more of me. Right, it's difficult. It's like you're this huge presence. You're in this, you're in this big, beautiful God frame. You're a very good looking man too. And inside of that is somebody who not only wants to do comedy, but can also do very subtle, nuanced, dramatic acting as well. And so how do you like, you, like,
you know you obviously have to account for how you come across and so they can only put you in those types of characters and those characters aren't historically super funny or super sensitive you know so it's like i just i mean until you get to know me and like i think we've had a little bit of time with each other some of us but it's like i just you know it's my first time doing a comedy doing doing minecraft finally with jack black and i'm like jesus christ finally i'm like or just getting into s andl like that's that's all that matters to me like just all I would do. You killed it on SNL back.
Yeah. So funny. Yeah, now you've got the juice where I'm sure you can go to your team and say, hey, so I'd like to do parts like X, Y, or Z. Can you go out there and see... Or create, by the way. I mean, like you created...
Well, you're busy doing your job, they can do theirs trying to bring you options in those areas because you've got the juice to... Where, like, a part is written not for a guy with your physical type, but you've got enough juice now where they can actually change what that actor might be,
what that character might look like without changing any of the dialogue, you know? Yeah. Yeah, you should tell. Yes, he agrees with you. But, yes, they can search it out, but I wonder, do you have like, because you mentioned Rhodes Plum and the movie
that you wrote and directed, which... What was... By the way, when you first started directing, and this is a Jason question, did you love that shift to directing? I love it. I mean, I don't want to actually be in front. I'd rather be behind the camera.
Like, I love every... You're like J.B. J.B. is the same. Yeah, I mean, like, that's where it's at. I mean, there's top and bottom jokes there. You say you don't want to be in front, you want to be in the... But I don't have it fully written right now, but you can just come back to me on that. Check your text.
Check your text. Working the check. I mean, you love being behind the camera, right? Oh, God. Yeah, I would stay back there and never, never act again. Although I do like acting, and I also... Acting in something that I'm directing, I really love just because, as you said, I love being overwhelmed with the amount of work and responsibility as opposed to just hiding in the trailer. You know, like, I'm a glutton for that stuff.
But you drop it in, like, on smoking aces and shit like that. Yeah, that's hilarious. Like, you got to, like, that stuff is like, you know, when you have little roles that come in, you're like, I want to support this and come in and do something. Yeah, I love that. Of course. I love if I can add and get the budget of whatever they need to do. Yeah. But I'd rather not have all the, I don't need to be the lead of this.
I'd rather make my movies and I like them small. I don't want to direct like a massive, this is probably the biggest it'll ever be. Like when I directed Chief of War, I directed four or five units. The finale is on the lava field. Dude, here's a crazy story. So you might ask this earlier, Will, like a crazy story about Chief of War. When we first wrote it, the whole finale is about, these two cousins fighting over the big island and the volcano goes off in history and it's literally
snowing ash and the volcano's coming down and the volcano it's it's kind of like let's just say it's 50,000 verse 10,000 and the volcano comes down and wipes out the person who lives in that territory and that's how Kamehamea won in history so when we wrote this I literally saw on the calendar in the production meeting, I go, boom, volcano's going to go off. And everyone was laughing me like, no, no, no, it's not going to go off. We cut to, we're there the night before. We're driving between Monoloa and Monocaia. And I tell my partner, I'm like, bro, it's going to go off.
I know it. And about four hours later, production calls, Monoloa goes off, which is probably 10 plus years since it went off. Wow. Manoloa goes off. We obviously break because no one's worked during a volcano. So we're checking, you know, Eric, air quality and all those kind of things and they're like yeah we're good to go so the next day we go
kill away it goes off that's the first time in human written history that both volcanoes went off i go and i shoot eight days i wanted to shoot the fight so it was like we're in the daytime and it goes into night i want to see the night i want to shift into blue light i want to i want to go through the sunset i want to go into blue light so i'd shoot the whole fight and reverse so we show up at four o'clock in the morning you're ushering in 300 extras 100 something and you're massive fucking battle dude yeah on lava fields so any anyone falls gets hurts where do you put the potty's how do you hide this i mean just all the schematics of like how do you shoot this massive epic piece in the area where it happened yeah so we shoot it there um i got about four to five units i'm directing at the
same time where i built it where i can shoot simultaneously so they can be used as extras in the back as I'm shooting this one as I'm shooting that so I kind of designed the whole fucking thing where I can and the 80's just like what what what I'm sitting in the production meeting and I have it all balanced out and yeah dude the fucking volcanoes this thing went off on the eighth day we end and the volcano stops the day we end both volcanoes end so were you getting the sort of the production value of those volcanoes going off we sent the people up to go shoot some stuff yeah but did you have ash coming down down on your shots and stuff?
No, no, we didn't have Ash coming down in our scene otherwise we wouldn't have been working because it was pretty bad for our health. But we had Ash and all that stuff coming down. So it's a huge massive scene where we shot it in reverse so that way we can shoot all our key characters in the same light. But it's all, yeah, it's completely in reverse. Wow.
It was meant to be. It's a massive feat. So the finale is like, that's my, that was like, I'm shooting the finale. And everyone's like, there's no way we'll pull this off. I'm like, I can't wait to see this. I've seen some of the posters around town. It looks awesome.
And it's all in our language. It's all in a Lelo, Hawaii. So you're like, you're going to be like, it's such a beautiful language. It's the most beautiful language. It's so rad. I mean, you're going to love it. Yeah, I can't wait to see it.
We'll be right back. And back to the show. You were talking about shooting that. That's pretty rad that scene on the lava field and shooting that. And you've done a lot of kind of big, epic. scenes like that you've acted in a lot of them was in but like aquaman like didn't you have like underwater fight scenes basically oh yeah yi like how did you pull all that kind of stuff what was that process like
lots of stuntmen i don't want to do it's it's brutal man it's brutal it's it's that's that's stuff's hard i mean fighting in a suit that putting that suit on i mean i would the best superhero in the world is lego batman come on black come on black dude my dude my son you're the best bad you're the greatest batman in the world the greatest well i mean you're the fucking best in the world come on well you are batman
thanks tell me more black that's a good impression and sometimes very very dark gray um listen uh that's very kind of you but i mean you've
you know you're aquaman and you had you had to you know where all the put all that shit on do you like having to do that stuff like put all the fucking soon on no no i don't no but you do it yeah the tattoos it's all hard bro sorry it's all hard but then you go and do stuff but in the same time you do like like the like dune like going to working with uh denny i mean it must be i love those movies i love those movies i love those you guys hear what happened right now no no check this story out so i'm in i'm in japan
with my son's dream is to go to japan so his 16th birthday we go with the whole family and i'm with him and i'm like gosh he he's trained martial arts his whole life he always wants to act i'm like you're never acting there's no way i'm not i'm not letting you act he does like school plays in tapanga right that's it that's the extension of like his acting skills yeah yeah you know um but i'm just like i don't want my kid child act i don't want you in this business blah blah blah you know obviously the mother's been through, like, no, you're not, you're not doing it. Look at baby. Yeah, it's just like, yeah, it's just like, but he grew up with his dad being this thing. He just loves it, but he loves martial
arts. So cut to, I'm like, he's 16, I really want, it's time for my son to be with me and travel, and maybe he can do school abroad, so I ask the mother, and we're like, yeah, well, if he can come with me, I would like him to come to Dune, because if he wants to really wants to learn acting, I'm like, we're going to be at Chalemay, we're going to be at Deney, we're to be with Zendaya, he should be watching his father, like, day and day out, I want his work ethic to be, like, mine of the Midwest. I want him to see how hard it is, getting up at this time, doing this. Like, it's hard, you know what I mean?
It's not digging ditches, but it's fucking hard. And when you have to do something over and over, and if you're doing a fight scene all day long, like, no, you go 10 rounds, 12 rounds, but, like, this is all day, and you're in a suit that weighs 40 pounds, and you're, like, it's brutal. Yeah. And so I want him to, like, understand the business. So he's begging me to learn all this stuff.
So, all right, fine. Well, let's send Uncle Kale. Kale, I did Minecraft with. I did Dune with. He's a producer. I'm sure you guys know him. And so Kale Boiters? Yeah, Kail Boitur.
And it's just like, he's, dear friend. I was like, listen, we'll send him a stunt, you know. So we taped something for Wolf. We send it in. And Kail's like, what the fuck? Dude, your son does? Because he's been doing it his whole life. And he's like, wow, he does this?
I'm like, yeah, he's pretty good at. Do you think we can get him like a friendman role and he can do some fight scenes? and let him be on set. And he goes, dude, we're casting for the kids, for Shalamay and Zendaya's. Basically, like,
I guess it's like Skywalker and Leia. It's children of Dune. So it's the two kids. And I was like, all right, well, he doesn't, does he act?
I'm like, eh, you know, it's, you know, it's community theater. And anyways, they send it.
I'm in New Zealand. The mother's with him. He does his scene. you know we we we don't want i don't want to coach him at all right i don't know how to teach acting i don't have a fucking style it's just through sucking you know it's through sucking that i sucking a little less each year yeah that's my style like i've had 27 years of fucking sucking that right i figured it out so i don't really have a style yeah so i'm not going to i don't how to teach it so uh my dear friend cliff curtis who i looked up to and he was in the in the show
with me i was like can you talk to my son a little bit about acting and he talks to him a little bit wolf does the scene we tape it we send it in and they fucking love it and i'm like holy shit uh he's like we want him to come to to london and test oh my god i'm like dude what and i had to fly from new zealand to london and my son goes into a room with denny valnew and it has to test with five girls and it's three and a half hours long I'm so fucking stressed out yeah and like
way more stress than you would be for yourself I mean bro like I don't even have like I'm fine no I'm freaking out because my son is just wild he's so wild and amazing but he just I guess he was beautiful
like you know Mary Parenthood was texting me and he's killing he's doing great but he had to do like a really hard scene that even if I had to do that scene there's no way i could pull that off and to do that for the first time and this kid killed it and he did it on his own i didn't help him at all how about that and i'm doing fucking dune with my son right that's amazing i didn't know that i literally just we got the part premiere bro the premiere of of chief of war we flew to hawaii we did the premiere i think on the 18th we got on a plane that
night we landed on the 19th my daughter's 18th was the 20th we flew out the 21st we landed in Budapest on the 22nd. He went to work on the 23rd. Jeez. His first goddamn scene. No way. Shooting my pants. He's with Zendaya.
He's in it. I'm like, my baby, 16 years old. And he just killed it. I was crying. I was a fucking wreck. I was so proud of it. And did he ever go, did he go, dad, you were right? Did he say you were right?
This is really fucking hard. He's so hard. He's like, it's so hard. He's like, pop on, so much. respect for you now and he and he understands every person that works with me now it's going like yeah i need help i need help these are the people that help you you don't have any scenes of them do you i don't this but in the future but i'm like i'm just there and i'm watching him and and you know denny who i fucking love and he's just like he's he's just he loves wolf and he's just doing a great job and
so i'm like it's the craziest feeling how incredible yeah and i'm like god damn it dude i just didn't want him to do it but he's i'm not going to lie to you like he's so good i I'm not surprised. Look at his parents. I'm not surprised either. And I also think, like, you want your kids to just be better than you. And I'm like, this motherfucker's going to be, like, he's going to blow me away. He's so goddamn present. Two things I want to say.
One is you've paved the way because you're a great dude. And it's no surprise to me that he's great because you're great. And it's no surprise to me that you deserve it in this time. Think about the year you've had that you're doing. You've got Chief of War, this thing that's really personal to you and about your family. And now you have your immediate family. son coming and working with you it must what an incredible feeling you must have in your heart this year about where you're at just just in that just think about that it's pretty rad i start dune i start
august first and this comes out so i start dune august first i went and watched my son yeah it's great on the day it's yeah you you put in a lot of hard work i tell you you know what jason i'll tell you something that my son said to me recently my son abel a friend of ours uh whom we all know had it had something happened in their life and it was public and uh you know it's like sort of shocking so my son abel comes to me and he says uh hey i heard about that thing is so-and-so okay and i said yeah yeah they're fine it all worked and he goes you know i was just thinking man thank god we're not as famous as them because you know yeah and i go first of all you're not famous at all a yeah and b fuck you man And he meant it, too.
He was just like, thank God we're not his family. Thank God we're not so famous. Yeah, how about that, Jason? Because you can't really hide. Can you? I can't hide at all. Yeah, and so how are you with that
with fan interaction and taking photos and things like that? I really, I'm really good when it's like set for that time. Yeah. It's like really, here's the hard thing. It's like, when I'm, we're all human. So I'm like, I'm down.
But if I'm with my kids, don't even, it's just people don't have really respect or they don't really think. It just makes the kid so uncomfortable. But if I'm with my kids, I'm like, don't, yeah, but I'm like, I'm like, you're never going to get, I can't take my attention away from these beautiful things that I barely get to see. Yeah. I'm like, it's a very challenging thing to navigate, but at the same time, it's that time to do it
or if I'm not, if I'm by myself, I'm like, yeah, hell yeah. But the cool thing is, is like, I love it when it's kids because it's like, my, Minecraft like right now they're like it went from Aquaman and then it went into like I'm garbage man now I know you guys probably haven't seen Minecraft but Minecraft I'm like the garbage man now and so it's fucking cute as shit so all these little kids
are like garbage man and I'm like yeah what's up so I'll take kids to the kids but it's a grown ass man I'm like just just buy me a beer yeah right yeah try not to be weird about it just hang out like I would imagine I would imagine the sequel to that is probably brewing right when do you
When do you guys start that? Oh, dude, we're right into it. Yeah. It's like, I mean, I'm into this motherfucker in March maybe. Look at you, Johnny Franchise. I love it. I know. Tell me about it, man.
Don't get fucking fastened barking down the door. Hopefully Chief goes again. Really? Christ. Yeah, I moved everything to New Zealand, too. I'm like, New Zealand and Hawaii, I'm building studios down there with Cliff and Tyca. So we're trying to, we're trying to like. No way.
Yeah, so I just want to be boom, boom, boom. That's great. Have you ever been in New Zealand? I've never. When I was a little kid, I'd love to go. go back are you is that where home is home is now montana in the states and uh new zealand so yeah wow and i in in hawai still i have but it's like i'm basically trying to build studios between hawai and new zealand that's amazing that's amazing shoot everything there it's just
you get to a certain place from like yeah the quality of life where do i want to be who don't want to be with you know i don't want to like it's still tax incentives and i'm like this is where i want be. And so, like, if everyone can come down here, we made Minecraft in New Zealand. We made Chief of War down there. I made wrecking crew, which is coming out. Like, I just made everything in New Zealand or it's going to go to Hawaii. That's great. What's your favorite thing to do with your, I was going to ask you, what you work so much? It sounds like, like, what do you do in your downtown? But, like, obviously, to spend time with family, what's your favorite thing to do with your kids or with family when you're not working? I mean, we rock climb. So it's like,
I tell my kids out of rock climbing the whole life. So we rock climbing, like, that just keeps us in the outdoors. And rock climbing. surfing or... This is a real man, Jason. You should be ashamed to yourself. I really am. You know, I used to rock climb when I was a little kid,
but now it hurts my hands too much as I get older. It's just, there's nothing soft about a rock. It's just scratchy. It's like my hands to be strong and tough. I know. I see you got a Band-Aid on the one finger and I'm like, that would just,
I'd have to cancel the podcast if I had a band-aid on my finger. You push right through it, don't you? And then music, man. I started playing my kids. My daughter was a sing. So I started playing music, and they kind of moved me into bass because they both started doing everything else.
And I just love playing music with them. Is it like a family band? Well, it's not a family band. I started making a, I started doing, I have a vodka company, so I, uh, I don't know It's called Halif, Relief. It's called Maley. Maly. Relief.
That's actually a good name for a lot. I'm trying to look at the hat. I'm trying to see. It looks like, no. Maly. Mealy Yeah So we have a vodka company
In Montana And so it's been nice to Like have these gatherings Where you get together with everyone And we play music And we play our favorite songs So we play Zeppelin and Sabbath And Chili Peppers
And Prince and zombie All great for the bass All those All those groups have John Paul Jones Incredible You've got a vodka company You're building a studio
Between New Zealand and Hawaii You're directing movies You're writing series And acting in series and acting in like eight franchises. And you seem so, like, chill about it all. And you seem really happy. Yeah, and like, yeah.
I mean, what, what pisses you want? Like, you seem like, you're fine, sure, whatever. Are we late? That's cool. I'll just wait for you. I'm pretty pissed. I got to lose a bunch of weight that I'm getting ready for this role. You know what's about it?
All right. But that's everyone's thing. I got to do a little extra. I got to take care of myself. How do you, what's your favorite? How was it going with you guys? Like, listen, I'm 46. You guys are, you know, you see.
You know, you said you're 55. We got 10 years on you. Yeah, yeah, 10 years on me. I'm like... What's your favorite way of dropping pounds? You know, I... Not eating or exercise? So, I don't exercise, and I don't, and I eat whatever I want.
And I eat whatever I want. So, and I drink. You can have a... Basically, when I stop drinking and I eat smart and I exercise, I lose weight. Okay, gotcha. Oh, yeah, your body must go into shot. Generally, I just keep it like, I don't do it until I have to. Yeah.
but I my problem is like with all the things that you're taking off like oh you do this do this the thing that I don't do is I don't take care of myself well you will you will you still got time yeah yeah so you got time you got to go like oh this is a certain point where you take care of one one one kidney stone you'll change your life oh haven't had one yet yeah okay well thanks granddad listen I think but but how many people are listening right now going fucking momo doesn't even work out and he looks like I know I'm gonna fucking throw myself There must have been a time, there must have been a time when you were a gym rat and you put on all that size on that claim. No, it's only when I was like, you know, I grew up skateboarding.
I was a skateboarding and rock climber. So when I did Conan, they made me put all that, they made me train and learn all that stuff. I mean, you do it for roles. Sure. And that's what's great about acting. They teach all these new things. And so, you know, you learn that. And then obviously for Aquaman, I had a train and, you know, you're with all these best trainers.
But I don't want to live like that. And I don't find, like, I, so what I did is I would build rock climbing gyms in our training facilities because I don't want to do sit-ups and I don't want to, I would just rock-climed. Yeah, one of the greatest joys in the world is food. Yeah, I would just rock climb to do more. Hey, man, relax. To, like, kind of like, the things that you love to do. Yeah, and, yeah, you think you're in shape until you try a pull-up, and that's, that's a lot of rock climbing makes, right?
It's just like. Yeah, it's just, I just try, I just want to have fun doing things I like to do. So, I mean, like, I say physical doing things I love to do. I just, like, I think I probably get hurt more lifting weights. If I do lift weights, it's very light now, or I do, like, kettlebells, which has really helped, like, just for, like, my, like, legs. But I do pretty light weight. You can avoid injury by just lifting chopsticks, like Sean, you know.
Into sodium. I'm just thinking, here we got two guys who both don't work out and eat whatever they want. And one is Jason Mamoa and one's Sean Hayes. I'd love to see it. Just a speedo shot side by side the two of you. It'd be so good. Although, J.B., you were talking about
you were lifting really lightweights recently and you were saying how hard it was. That lasted three days. Did it really? It did, yeah. I'll get back at it though. I've had a burger every day for the last three days.
Really? You're great. Yeah. Babe, do you work out? No, not really. I mean, I do cardio, but I don't lift weight and I should. I mean, like, when you're directing,
it's so hard. The hard thing for me is like, I'm such a, I come from such an art. artist mentality where it's like it's really hard to balance the physicality when I'm like I'm giving everything to right these things that you're doing you're up too early too to yeah and the thing is like I don't sleep much anyways which is fine it's just I don't if I if I if I burn out doing this to for just I just don't take care of myself keep doing whatever you're doing whatever you're doing yeah whatever you're killing it just yeah my favorite thing one time memo you and I were in
Vegas we were at for like cinema con or something we were on a shuttle bus yeah we were going we were going back to the airport and he had like a rucksack like a roughly hewn rucksack and it was just filled with loose beers it was the it was the greatest I'm like he's got a bag with him and I was like
oh it's a cooler so smart I know so jealous all right what are you going to do the rest of the day today Jason you got you got the evening I go have dinner with my lady all right yeah I'm going to go just have a nice
romantic dinner my lady who's your lady i should know should we adrea adre arjona andre arjona yeah nice name movie yeah she's uh she's she's doing a movie thomas crown affair right now
oh wow so we're gonna go have a nice dinner and then i go back to budapest to go back to dude yeah unbelievable i can't wait the kids are in the kids are in budapest so we're gonna be together and uh wolfie's working and low my daughter lola's there so her friends are coming over and we're just uh celebrating because I get them in the summer,
so we're going to go do fun stuff, having my birthday here in a couple days, so big party. Yeah, you have plans for your birthday? I think he was going to stay at the house, maybe get a DJ and just, like, eat. You're going to stay at the house with a DJ? A DJ at the house and just eat.
Get Scottie. Scotty, I snuggle. My husband DJs sometimes. Sure he does. Send him over. He's in London. He'll do the gate. Listen, we'll make a deal here.
Momoa, you're going to have to wait till, what, 50 for the big one, right? I mean, I feel like that's, that's, when you get to our age, you got to wait for like 50, 60, 70, 80 for the big ones. You can't do it every year, right? Yeah. No, I just think being, I'm like, I'm with some really cool friends that I haven't seen a long time. How long is it? You haven't seen us for a long time. Can we get an invite?
I would love for you guys to come. We like to party. It's Budapest, so it's like, it's pretty far. We got mileage. You're always invited. Listen, dude, continue success. One of the all-time great dudes, and you deserve all of it. Honestly.
I'm so happy for you and you see it looks so great and you seem so happy and just continued I'm so psyched that you and your son get to do this just all of it is great you're a raised sunshine dude I can't wait I'm a huge tune fan I can't wait for the time yeah I can't wait for you guys yeah chief of war Apple TV on August first as well I mean just just all of it all of it's so rare congratulations buddy keep it up yeah keep going thanks payment all right guys all right nice to see you see you pal all right nice going big hug soon all right to see you hello bye pal
he slammed it he's a slammer i love it yeah nice going a while you know i thought it might have been baroque obama i'm i was pleasantly surprised it was jason mamoa you know those are the two hawaians that you know that's it that and king command mail but he's gone so um yeah that that that was great this is great oh it's such a war the warmest guy really fun yeah just so cool down to earth yeah so so good i love the hit that i love that his pants came down at shit fuck Is that what it's called? Yeah. At shit fucks, you got taken from behind with his shorts down.
Wow. It was just the net result of all that. That's when I perked up. We might want to revisit the transcript on that, Jay. I don't know. You know what I mean? And also, you want to fall on the wrong side of Mamoa? I mean, you know.
But you truly thought shitfucks was in Chelsea. Is it not? I thought, but wait, you know, it's great about him as like, I had no idea he was that prolific in this business. Dude, he's a busy man. Yeah, he's just doing it all. Big, huge star. Yeah, turns out. Just a guy trying to mind his own business.
And then you're like complaining about tech rehearsals. Yeah, I know. Hey, yeah, when do you go up, Shawnee? It's got to be close. Two days, three days. Three days. Oh, my God. I can't wait to see you.
Oh, my God. I don't normally have my wearing my hair like this. Well, we're not talking about the hair right now. You look great. We're talking about three days. Yeah, yeah. J.B., you're not going over, right? J.B., we're going to go over and see him.
Yeah, no, I saw it. It's good. Yeah, that's fine. Yeah. I saw it in New York. And plus, I was just there in London, staying with him. Okay, walking the fucking stairs. I liked it the first time.
I preferred it in the States. I'm a fan of the original. Yeah, I know, I'm excited. You got so beleaguered, the guy. Yeah, go ahead. No, I was just going to do a bye. Oh. No, we know.
We saw you look out the window. Well, no, I was thinking, I was like, you know, I didn't, I knew. I didn't know he was from Hawaii. I thought it was like, but, you know, Aloha, not only means hello and in Hawaiian. Sure. What else does it mean? What does it mean? No, no.
It means something like, bye! Bye! Bye! Oh my God! Oh, hi! Aloha! Smartless. Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smart less. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.